[Music]
it's in care homes that the covid
vaccine will really make a difference
55 residents of andrew cohen house are
in line for the jab
and the odds are it'll save the lives of
two of them
michael is relieved it's his turn
confidence
if you get it less because you've had
the vaccination
it's all about confidence in tomorrow
pharmacies are about to join the rollout
2.6 million people have had the vaccine
over the last month
that many need to get it every week if
the government has to meet its target
of immunizing the 15 million most
vulnerable by mid-february
but some gps say they're being held back
unable to secure
enough doses to immunize patients as
fast as they'd like
our main problem really is vaccine
supply we could
do a whole load more if we had more
supplier vaccine
be nice to know when it's coming because
we don't get much notice
and sometimes there's quite a lot of
uncertainty about whether it'll actually
be received
the government blames supply but it
won't make public the number of doses
being made available by astrazeneca and
pfizer to the annoyance of mps on a key
select committee
there's a huge national interest in this
and you are
keeping uh the figures secret
and spending huge amounts of money
that's
an extraordinary position why are you so
phobic to numbers
the one thing we're not doing is saying
to you oh we've had x million of
deliveries i'm saying to you
that we have the clear line of sight for
volumes
all the way through till end of february
which means i'm confident
of hitting the target of the four most
vulnerable cohorts
astrazeneca says it hopes to ramp up
production
to two million doses a week imminently
but it's been told to keep quiet on how
many it actually delivers
for security reasons this former
pharmaceutical industry executive
sympathizes with those now feeling the
political heat
you can't really speed up the process of
growing the cells in which you then grow
the carrier virus which of course is
your eventual vaccine that process is
defined by
by biology so you can't scale up as
quickly as perhaps we would like you've
got to be
patient and do it in a really fastidious
way making sure there are no
possibility of any anything going wrong
but hospitals are now
so stretched that the government is
urgently scaling up the sharp end
mass vaccination centers will soon offer
appointments around the clock
and this asda in birmingham is clearing
out the clothes
to make way for a pop-up clinic
desperate times
and the vaccine is the way out thomas
more sky news